the european parliament approved the
eu's next
long-term budget and a historic recovery
fund amounting to a total of 1.8
trillion euros
europeans and businesses will be able to
receive vital financial support from the
start of 2021
the brexit transition period ends on the
31st of december
meps discussed the future relationship
between the eu and the uk
and voted on contingency measures in the
event of a no deal
the european parliament awarded the 2020
sako of prize for freedom of thought to
the democratic opposition in belarus
for their peaceful protest against the
authoritarian president
alexandra lukashenko they are demanding
a new election and the release of all
156 political prisoners in the country
four different vaccines are currently
under review by the european medicines
agency
meps discussed how to fairly and
effectively deploy a vaccine
european commission president ursula van
der lion said the eu would aim to start
vaccination on the same day in all
eu countries
swapping bottled water for tap water
could save eu households more than 600
million euros a year
parliament adopted new rules that
tighten quality standards for tap water
and improve access to safe drinking
water for all europeans